après plus de 15 ans chez momon Factory
le producteur exécutif et associé de
l'entreprise
Eric Fournier annonce son départ
momentan Factory le studio multimédia
qui illumine les sites historiques et
naturels autant que les grands
événements culturels du monde entier
s'apprêtent à perdre finalement l'une de
ses étoiles il est avec nous ce soir
Eric Fournier bonsoir bonsoir et c'est
un primeur que vous nous annoncez votre
retraite ouais ben c'est très jeune
c'est gentil mais ça fait un bout de
temps que je réfléchis à la prochaine
étape de ma vie je vais avoir 60 ans
l'automne et j'ai grandi avec Liberté 55
ans je vais commencer à dire aux gens
moi j'aimerais ça là commencer à passer
la main avoir une nouvelle gang qui
amène môme une facture et une autre
étape c'est le moment de faire ça c'est
le bon moment pour une factory un
changement aussi important parce que
vous vous êtes avec d'autres l'âme de
cette entreprise là je pense que le
moment est bien choisi au sens où
en très bonne forme ça va bien c'est une
boîte qui a de beaux carnet de commande
a beaucoup de talents à l'interne des
gens de très grande qualité alors là
c'est le temps justement de faire une
transition
passer la main donnée aux gens plus de
responsabilités puis laisser à la
nouvelle génération le soin d'amener mon
même facteur un autre vingt ans un autre
100 ans vous êtes associé dans mon
manufactory donc partiellement
propriétaire de cette entreprise-là vous
allez demeurer propriétaire ou vous
quitter complètement non l'entendre que
j'ai avec mes deux associés Dominique et
section c'est que je me retire de
l'action en arrière on s'est entendu que
équitablement on allait tous les trois
contribuer 25% pour ouvrir le capital
puis dans le fond avoir partagé
l'entreprise avec un groupe d'employés
ah d'accord donc les employés vont
acheter le 25 % les employés vont
développer un programme ça va être
annoncé à l'automne pour encourager les
gens à faire partie de l'avenir de mon
manufacturing
au début quand on essayait d'expliquer
aux gens au banquiers il faut comprendre
qu'à l'époque c'était une carte de
crédit qui finançait mon manufacture
alors une des premières choses j'ai
essayé de faire c'est un plan d'affaires
puis essayer d'expliquer aux banquier
c'est que ce qui était mon manufacturing
il n'existait pas de comparer mais il
existe rien alors faites-vous convaincre
banquier les clients au furieux
développer dans le fond une entreprise
dans un nouveau domaine émergent
extrêmement créatif ça c'est ça demeure
pour moi quelque chose de très important
puis ensuite évidemment la covid passer
à travers la covid puis assurer la
pérennité de l'entreprise après le choc
qu'on a eu il y a deux ans trois ans
maintenant est-ce que l'entreprise c'est
complètement remise de la covid je pense
que c'est terminé derrière nous la
pandémie et on a ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on a réussi rapidement à se
passer du présentiel au virtuel on avait
un superbe carnet de commandes alors on
n'était pas dans une situation à risque
sauf que le défi c'était de gérer les
gens distances trouver des façons des
motiver des garder et là aujourd'hui le
marché a repris on recommence à aller
voir nos clients donc oui c'est derrière
nous quand on voit mon manufactory
là-bas c'est l'église de ses reins c'est
Reims et dans le centre c'est à Hong
Kong ouais et ici c'est à Montréal c'est
le pont Jacques-Cartier à cause d'ici
vous en avez fait des des projets est-ce
qu'il reste encore d'autres territoires
à explorer mais je pense que ce qui est
intéressant avec la technologie avec la
créativité c'est que j'avais des
territoires prédéterminés je pense c'est
là où la technologie peut nous amener
c'est c'est un peu
cette mission qu'on s'est donnée de dire
on fait ça en public et dans le fond
c'est d'utiliser les technologies qui
viennent du web qui viennent de
l'intelligence artificielle qui viennent
des jeux vidéo et l'appliquer au monde
en réel pour que les gens aient le goût
de se retrouver en public
ça vous inquiète l'intelligence
artificielle moi je suis toujours
sensible aux questions de propriété
intellectuelles moi s'il y a quelque
chose qui m'inquiète c'est jusqu'à quel
point l'intelligence artificielle va
respecter la créativité des gens leur
savoir-faire leur unicité alors c'est un
peu mon souci à aujourd'hui vous êtes
engagé dans quoi actuellement je viens
d'excepter un poste au Conseil
d'Administration pointe Académia
c'est c'est un musée hyper important on
avait
fait des projets avec eux on a découvert
à quel point
les gens ne connaissent pas bien
l'histoire de Montréal et comment un
musée est important pour traduire un
enfant qui est habitué à tout voir sur
son téléphone quelque chose en réel
alors pour moi l'aspect de ramener les
gens ramener les jeunes leur donner des
expériences en réel c'est tellement
important et est-ce que vous avez une
autre aventure entrepreneuriale devant
vous non non
je vais
prendre un peu de temps pour moi avec ma
blonde puis ça va être une prochaine
étape vous savez j'ai fait des premières
années je fais du bon je suis bon
Verdier chez ses parents j'ai fait du
beau sur du soleil et puis chez mon
médecin là je pense je vais faire du
bien pour les prochaines années et vous
faire du bien aussi merci
Eric Fournier merci beaucoup merci j'ai
une bonne chance pour la suite au
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]